It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa!
I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 160th episode today!
BAU BAU!
Good morning FUWAMOCO Good Morning!
I feel like I sound like a...
I feel like I sound like that.
That's a little bit too much for the mornings, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Good morning, Ruffians.
Thank you Ruffians for joining us.
For Ruffians who are joining us for the first time, I saw some Ruffians happy that they're able to wake up earlier time.
Congratulations!
But some explanation is in order.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yes!
Now, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO morning!
BAU BAU!
Come morning.
You woke up a bit early for this.
You're awake and now you're not going back to sleep, okay?
Good.
Okay.
BAU BAU.
Well, you know, there's been a bunch of things going on.
Exciting things.
Maybe we can share them with the Ruffians right away here, Moco-chan.
I don't know if that's that exciting though, Moco-chan.
You woke up 10 minutes ago.
Maybe not.
Good morning!
10 minutes ago.
Maybe not, maybe I'm glitchy.
Let's go right into it then, Moco-chan!
Oh my god, she avoided!
Is what I would like to say, but uh... Unfortunately it's not.
Don't tell me there's been a parasite in Moco-chan.
Ruffians!
There's been another Pero Sighting!
Moco-chan, let's just take a look so that we can know what to avoid.
You know, the Ruffians, they woke up at 5.30am!
They just need to know and get on with their days.
Well, here we go.
Where is Pero Sighting?
De-den!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I thought you said tasty but you wrote nasty.
Did you make a typo?
Tasty and nasty are pretty similar.
Thank you for the food!
Look, I'm sure it's delicious once you cut into it, you know?
It's not filled with muscle.
No, I'm sure it's filled with sprinkles or something or a strawberry paste or something, you know?
Yeah?
Not strawberry jam, strawberry paste.
Paste.
Yeah.
Ruffians, what do you think?
You know, when you make a cake, don't you think it tastes way better because you had a bunch of fun making it?
Yeah!
Ruffians, you have made a cake before, right?
Right?
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, no.
No.
It's not too late to make a cake, you know what?
Actually, you can make a mug cake, too.
Yes, yes!
You can have some flour, and an egg, and some butter, and you just mix it together.
And vanilla, and maybe some sugar.
Stuff.
Yeah, then you can make a mug cake, and that's a cake.
Does cake mix count?
Yes.
That counts, yes.
Monkeys count.
But it's a good start, that's the important thing.
It's a good start, yeah.
Yeah.
Start at the one cake, then continue on.
But such an amazing pero cake!
I hope you enjoyed it with a bunch of friends, you know?
Yeah!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I like this, you know?
Ruffians best pero cakes too, you know?
More pero cakes, less Pero Sightings.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Okayu-senpai!
She just finished her second solo concert at Kaya Arena!
It was her first solo concert in three years!
Nice transition.
BAU BAU!
Poison.
Nya.
Respect.
Person.
Nya.
Respect.
Poison.
BAU BAU!
But in the key visual here you can see a very, very outdoors, wild Okayu-senpai.
Yeah, because she has a new outfit!
A new outfit!
Look at it!
It's fuzzy!
Yeah, long hair!
A bit wild looking.
The tail's a little bit longer.
I can't see it that well.
She has some ouchies on her tummy, but that's okay.
She might have gotten some bites or something.
Wild cat.
Outdoors cat.
Okayu-senpai.
She had a summer concert.
Yeah!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we did a watchabong too, so...
Well, friends, if you're curious about it, you can catch it on SPWX.
It's streaming to get there.
There will be an archive available for about a month.
But!
You can watch it together with us.
There is also a free sneak peek over on Okayu-senpai's channel.
So please check it out if you're curious as well.
You know what, it's a solo concert, right?
You know, it's a little bit different than the 3D concert, you know?
Look at all the onigiri out there!
Right.
But it was really amazing, you know, Okayu-senpai, she sang a bunch of her new songs and older songs too!
Yeah, we were surprised!
Right, you know, and it was just a very, very, like, well-rounded act.
Very Okayu-senpai.
Oh, you know, you got to know every little bit of her.
I feel like she performed so many songs!
Right!
It was just to the point where I feel like...
Do I-senpai always sing that many songs?
You'll definitely check out the free version!
15 minutes of a sneak peek into the concert and if you're like, I want to get to know Okayu-senpai even more, you can check it out on SPWN.
We just really, really loved it.
You know, solo concerts are such a special, special thing that our senpai have been able to do, so we're really happy to be able to see that moment, you know?
And you know, we'll continue to work hard towards our dream of one day having a FUWAMOCO solo concert!
I hope that our delusional solo concert, Moco-chan, that we can have it so it's super fluffy and super fuzzy, you know?
I get FUWAMOCO now.
Yeah.
I would like that, you know?
Maybe!
You know, somebody watching goes, I don't really know who FUWAMOCO are.
But I'll check this out, it seems fun.
And then after that, oh, now I understand.
Thank you, Okayu-senpai!
Congratulations!
BAU BAU!
I'm looking forward to seeing more of her cute new outfits too, right?
So what do you think, Ruffians?
Do we have
Wild dog FUWAMOCO outfits.
You know what's even cooler than a wild dog?
Demon dog.
Unless he's just everyday.
BAU BAU!
Continuing about this concert, FUWAMOCO, we just got back from our concert at Anime Boys 2!
Together with B-senpai, we performed at
Anyway Boston, for the hololive meet super karaoke party!
It was the first ever event like this in the US.
Yes!
It was super duper fun!
We were so nervous though!
Unbelievably nervous!
Yeah, we were shaking a little bit beforehand, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Yeah, but you know, Okayu-senpai talked about eating bento.
I had the fish out of the bento.
I did not even bother touching the bento.
No.
Fish energy.
Yeah, Moco-chan was brave.
I did not.
I thought maybe, worst case scenario, I might throw up the fish, but... That was the risk you're gonna take, Moco-chan!
Yes.
It didn't happen, so yay.
But you know, we did sing a bunch of songs and danced a number of them too!
Classic anime songs, city pop songs, and of course hololive songs, including our very own original Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★!
I think the Ruffians really liked that one, huh?
One Ruffian.
I cried a lot.
But it was happy tears though.
Because it was happy tears, I felt a bit proud.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
We're watching when you're waving the camera because you're- Oh, I'm being silly.
We're waving back at you.
But we are just so so happy to be able to hear your voices and see your smiles, too, Ruffians.
You know, it's always hard to say goodbye at the end of a performance.
What?
You know, maybe sometimes we don't have to say hello.
Right, because I shall be saying hello again!
Soon!
Because, well, Ruffians, you might have heard that there's going to be a hololive World Tour going on!
Yes!
Yeah, the hololive Stage World Tour "Synchronize!"
A new tour is setting sail this year too!
With this big...
Cool!
Cute!
Amazing!
Synchronize!
Key visual here!
And this year, compared to last year, we have a new tour!
Last year we have Calli-senpai!
Nenechi-senpai!
Ollie-senpai!
IRyS-senpai!
And Nerissa!
Not senpai.
No.
You know and it's a world tour so we're gonna be making a bunch of stops across all the places.
Sydney, New York, Kuala Lumpur, a bunch of bunch of places.
But you know a tour also needs special guests.
Special guests, right?
And FUWAMOCO, we are now the special guests of the Vancouver Storm Adventure!
BAU BAU!
It's the best time for living in Canada!
It's our first time, so... We'll be at Anime Revolution on August 3rd!
So we hope that you'll be able to come and see us there, Ruffians!
Yeah!
Are you going?
We saw some Ruffians already have their tickets!
We'll see you there then!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Are you gonna be at the New York City show?
How fun!
We won't be there though.
But you'll have fun, that's the number one thing, you know?
You know, maybe Canada's a little bit far for some Ruffians, but... But there's other stuff coming too, I'm sure!
Yeah, you do!
So maybe I'll be...
Come to where you are, soon!
It just has to get announced though, maybe?
Oh, there's other stuff there.
Please continue to look forward to more announcements from the hololive STAGE World Tour "Synchronize!"
And Ruffians, you better be ready to synchronize with us too!
BAU BAU!
Do you think maybe they chose us for this because of our skills?
The skills that we synchronize?
We didn't synchronize just now, so... We did just now.
When?
When we said "synchronize."
Just now.
I don't... Did you say "synchronize?"
I did.
Did she?
Synchronize... Didn't synchronize then.
Synchronize.
Nope.
Nope, not then.
I can't do it!
I'm not good at it!
Synchronize.
We did.
Yes!
I don't know.
Synchronize!
BAU BAU!
I can't force it.
Moco-chan, you can't just feel it!
Synchronize!
Are you happy now?
She finally felt it.
I don't think that counts.
Really?
No, I don't think that counts.
I think it counts.
Make me happy.
We will agree to disagree.
Not synchronizing on the agreement part.
BAU BAU!
Trying too hard!
Ruffians!
It's not anymore, you know, unofficial FUWAMOCO World Tour news.
But... Had a dream.
I had a dream about fans.
It's kind of a weird dream, but I felt happy.
What?
I felt happy at the end of the dream.
Then tell me your full dream!
Why did you feel happy at the end of it?
I don't know, it was just like a hum hum hum feeling.
Yeah, I'm the Ruffians.
For some reason I was like in a hotel.
And everyone else was there too.
Everybody from hololive, yeah.
But it was late at night and for some reason I decided to go down to the ground floor to get some mail.
I was like, oh I have to go get the mail.
But you know it's late at night so you're kind of in your pajamas.
Not so much in your pajamas.
And I didn't really want to put on pajama pants.
So I just had my pajama shirt.
Pajama shirt?
Yeah.
And you know, so I was like, okay, I'm going to go get the mail.
What?!
!
I'm just going down.
Just to put down my shirt.
See ya.
So I went to go get the meal and I got the meal and I was waiting to go back up in the elevator from the very bottom floor.
And you know, I was waiting the elevator gets there.
And I was surprised because the door is open.
And Elizabeth is just standing there naked.
And she was a little surprised because Fuwawa was here!
And so she just pressed the close button!
The close button!
Not the close button!
The door is closed!
And I guess she went back up and I was like, okay.
That's kind of weird.
But I guess, you know.
I guess!
So I don't know, you know.
So I just decided to wait for another elevator.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
I don't know, I just remember I was a little awkward, you know.
What do you say in a situation like that?
I don't know, but I was like, you know, it's okay.
I don't have pants on either.
It's good to have lots of hobbies, that kind of conversation.
And then I woke up.
I don't know, I guess you just like being one with the nature and the elevator and the hotel lobby late at night.
Did you stare?
Would you stare?
I did not stare.
I did not see anything except Elizabeth's flesh.
That was a happy dream?
I don't know how that was a happy dream.
I woke up feeling like...
Was it racist happiness because you were able to see Elizabeth in her dream?
Maybe.
I don't know.
I imagine, like, in Evangelion, you know where everyone's in the elevator all together.
No, it's the shoulder-to-shoulder.
It wasn't that big of an elevator, Moco-chan.
Why would you stand shoulder-to-shoulder?
Because we're having a conversation!
I'm just not looking her in the eye.
We don't even stand shoulder-to-shoulder!
I know, but... I'm not looking her in the eye, I'm just looking forward.
That's the safe place to look, you know?
At the door, at the elevator, as it goes upwards.
That's the place.
Apparently.
Yeah.
That was my dream.
I have dreams like that, Ruffians!
Hi!
Did you ask about... No, I think she didn't have them.
Because... She just didn't.
She just didn't.
Yeah.
You know, just like how I was like...
No pants.
Just exception.
Yeah, I'm just accepting it, you know.
You know, it's a late night.
Nobody's gonna be down there.
Understandable.
Whatever Mococo, I don't know Moco-chan was.
No, I was probably asleep.
Probably.
No hostiles!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, just normal.
I woke up feeling happy.
That was a dream?
It was a dream, Fufu.
It did not happen in real life.
No.
BAU BAU.
Was it a dream?
Yeah!
It did happen.
It is.
We went and had some fun.
Because we were on a Joypolis trip.
Together with Biboo and Kawii-san!
Oh my!
We had a bunch of fun together at the Frustrating Bargains, and I was like, what is Joypolis?
Joypolis?
We talked about it before, but it's like an arcade amusement park.
I was sick of one!
Yes!
And it's really fun.
It's amazing.
It's like, you know, like an arcade and a music park came together.
Yes!
That's what it's like, there's like roller coasters and other fun games and like rhythm games and stuff.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, and Zoidpolis.
It's so much fun.
So, you know, was Biboo tall enough to ride any rides?
That was the first thing we did!
There was, you know, like a little Sonic outside being like, how tall are you?
Sonic's this tall.
And we're like, oh, Biboo, go measure your height with Sonic.
And then Biboo was just, just tall enough.
Just a bit taller.
And we're like, oh good, you're not the same height as Sonic.
But then I realized, oh, that's for the kids.
Then there's a bunch of kids, I was like, oh, people, you have to get away.
Kids, they're in the way.
We actually did search up how tall Sonic is, but he's shorter, apparently.
Shorter than the sign was.
But yeah, we had a bunch of fun!
There was a special event going on for a singer-actor named Matsuken!
He sings the song Matsuken Samba.
So Matsuken Samba was played everywhere you went!
Matsuken is a oompa.
Habiba.
Calliope.
I didn't know who he was but now I think I know who he is.
We watched Matsuken's show.
His show on the stage which was just the MV playing.
Which I've seen already many times.
And then there were so many cute girls and you know there was Matsuken, Oshii and they had all this stuff.
And they had Uchiwa.
Matsuken!
Yeah!
We danced!
Karin-senpai didn't know the dance, but she did by hand.
Karin-senpai was dancing the most, you know.
And we went on the rollercoaster, which was like a rhythm game and also played Matsuken Samba.
And I was so scared.
I've never been so scared of Matsuken Samba ever.
It was very frightening.
I was like screaming and then I opened my eyes and he's just not in his costume.
He's just recording in the recording booth.
I was like, what the heck is going on?
It was a lot of fun and we got to play House of the Dead together!
Ruffians, I have to brag.
This is worth it!
I got number one.
Of the day!
And how's the day?
Number one of the day, okay?
It's not of a group.
Between Calli-senpai and Biboo.
Number one of the whole entire day!
I did not cheat.
You know, I just killed everything in my path with my steady aim and a very good strong fear of zombies.
Did you take a photo?
I would have taken a photo but they said no photos.
No photos.
Yeah.
So, I would have.
Yeah, and we got to the Fortune Forest, which we talked about before with Shiori and Nerissa before.
Nerissa got really really into the Fortune Forest.
I'll explain a little bit about Fortune Forest.
It's a forest that you go in and then you know you put in your name and all that stuff.
And then it asks you, what are you interested in?
Fortune, you know, is a little more about yourself, about your career, about romance, a bunch of different stuff.
It's very detailed, very personal, very correct.
And it's also in English, too!
Also, uh, interesting fortunes.
Yeah!
And, you know, there's a room inside of it.
A room called Fenyar's Gate.
Fenyar's Gate?
Gate.
Yeah.
And it will only open if you hold hands.
With your, what's it?
True love?
With your true love?
I don't know.
Or you could be the chosen one.
The chosen ones with the person you have a bond with.
You can see inside, but you cannot get in.
And it looks really cool in there.
And Nerissa was like, I can't go home until I go in there.
We found a way to get in there.
Yes.
And Biboo and Calli's up by us.
They are also crazy too.
They are also gamers.
We have to get into the room!
So, did you guys hold hands?
Yes.
We held hands how many times?
Yes, I held hands with Calli-senpai.
Moco-chan, you held hands with Biboo.
Then we held hands together.
Yeah.
Yeah, we had to do it a bunch of times.
Three times?
Four times?
Four times, we had to do it a bunch of times.
Yeah, but it felt good once we got in because, you know, the door opens.
How did they do it?
Oh my gosh!
They got in there!
How did they get in there?
Yeah, I would've got to do it twice.
Yeah.
We're not toys in a magical place.
But then you get your fortune printed on the wonderful Munchkin paper at the end too!
You know and then you can share your fortunes all together and talk about how accurate they are and how playful they are.
Laugh a lot.
Titan Attraction.
And I was very frightened.
I was holding onto Biboo like she was my child.
I was so scared.
It just reminded me of the haunted house with Calli-senpai.
They said not to push, but I remember pushing Calli-senpai so much.
I was like, I'm gonna push her again.
Yeah.
There was a bunch of other people.
And I think they were sort of shocked at how much we were screaming.
Yeah.
We're just into the rule, right?
Moco-chan!
We're really into it!
We're gonna get eaten by titans!
Yeah.
We survived.
Just so you know.
Just barely though.
Yeah.
Not all of us did though.
No.
But we also, we were on a transformers ride, and it was Biboo.
And I was carrying Senpai.
Yeah, and it goes upside down, and we have to spin upside down, and you hang upside down.
Yeah, Biboo and I were screaming so loud, I'm sure that everybody could hear us.
Yeah, we were carrying Senpai and I. We were screaming so, so loud.
Biboo and I, our hair was going everywhere.
Everywhere.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
And then we had snacks all together!
We drank a bajillion drinks!
We had the Matsuken Fruits OLE!
OLE!
Matsuken Fruits OLE!
We had a bunch of drinks and Biboo had some food too!
Ketchup all over her face, sauce everywhere!
On one cheek, on the other cheek, on her nose!
I would get the tissue, and then get it off of her cheek, and then she would take the tissue, and then she would push it on her nose, and then she had it on her nose!
I had to go take another tissue afterwards, and then go and wipe her face for her, because it was still everywhere!
Yeah...
Biboo.
There's something I'm a little sad about.
FUWAMOCO we were very good demodogs.
We were late.
We were good ones?
We weren't very good, Moco-chan.
We were late.
So it may be more Calli-senpai wait for us.
And while they're waiting, Calli-senpai, she went to go get some ice cream.
Ice cream!
And I don't know if you've had a Turkish ice cream before, Ruffians!
You might have seen it on YouTube!
Turkish ice cream!
Apparently she had some turkish ice cream.
But she didn't know the kind of game that is played with it.
So I told her to put ice in.
She didn't know.
Yeah.
So just as the match began, Kalli's and my uncle and Digby started getting ice cream hot!
Yeah, Digby gave us the ice cream, taking it away from Kalli-senpai for her to be like, it's too sweet!
We should've been on time!
I wanted to see that!
FUWAMOCO, it was a lot of fun!
But you know, there's actually some cool news!
In just one day from today!
Joyfulis is gonna be starting their whole live campaign!
Together with Nippon Apple!
Once again, once again.
Mocoto, you wanna share a picture?
Once again.
Yeah!
It's super duper cute!
They're gonna be having performances!
Yes!
And also a collab with the Halfpipe Tokyo!
Oh, the Halfpipe Tokyo!
Yes, which is a music game.
Which we weren't able to go on this time, but their songs are gonna be in it!
Yeah, you know, a bunch of different things.
Merchandise, a lot of food!
So if you're curious about Joyfuls, now is the time to go!
I think it's gonna be open for
Quite a while.
A few months.
A month more.
Please check it out.
Not a scary one.
No.
It's like a rhythm game.
Yes.
And it's very fun.
I went on with Nerissa last time.
Yeah, I went with Shiori.
And we did really poorly because of me.
It's really scary.
It goes fast and it spins and goes upside.
Not upside down but almost upside down.
Almost upside down.
Yeah.
And then you have to get the rhythm and stuff at the right time to be able to get a good score.
And I just didn't.
I gave up.
Yeah, Shiori and I started spinning too hard and we were like, wow, let's slow down a bit on this.
Yeah, but if you're curious and you're in Tokyo, please check it out.
This is so much fun, so I really recommend it.
There's also Nepo Labo themed Dippin' Dots.
Yeah, Nepo Labo Dippin' Dots.
Lots of fun!
Ice cream.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Should we take a look at our Doggie of the Day?
Okay.
It's a pose.
Moco-chan, maybe you have some encouraging words to share with us.
Maybe just a little bit.
Okay.
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
I know, sometimes I can feel like everyday is an uphill battle.
Every day, you feel like you're climbing an unending mountain.
But slowly and surely, with time and effort, you can overcome it, okay?
Remember what I said.
One step a day is seven steps legal.
Right, Ruffians?
All your efforts add up.
Even if you don't see them right away.
You will get results.
Something will change.
So let's keep doing our best towards what matters to us.
Towards our dreams together, okay?
I know you can do it!
You're amazing!
Ganbatte desu!
BAU BAU!
One step a day, seven steps a week.
Let's keep on remembering that, okay?
Ruffians remember how hard it gets, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, let's take a look at who our Doggie of the Day is today!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Sable!
BAU BAU!
That's the dog you meet for the beach, huh?
Yeah, I bet you she loves to swim, huh?
She's apparently very silly too.
Look at those ears!
Why is the ears so silly?
Floppy ears.
What a beautiful sunrise.
Sunrise too.
Sunset, sunrise.
What's he scared of?
I don't think Sable's scared of anything.
No.
Yeah, I know.
Maybe dolphins.
Dolphins are kind of silly.
I could understand that, yeah.
How does Sable bump bump Moco-chan?
I think it's like...
FUWAMOCO.
Moco-chan, you're looking up at the surface of the water while you do that?
Yes!
She's touching the water!
Yes
You know, being friendly and baw bawing at others too!
And dolphins.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Get out of her way.
It sounds like every day would be a fun one together with Sable there.
Make sure to give her lots of head pats and towel pats after the beats too.
Especially with all the sound.
FUWAMOCO!
Tense weather.
Not so great, huh?
It looks like it was a little bit of a moody weather adventure.
Yeah!
Thunderstorm!
Ka-shun!
Yeah!
You know, going out into the weather when it's raining lots or a little bit gusty can be a lot of fun, right?
Sometimes.
Do you like your Ruffians?
Huh?
Yeah!
Thunderstorms are cool.
They are cool.
Yeah?
Yeah.
I don't know out on the water though, huh?
Well, the thunderstorm, it's just being loud, right?
Not lightning.
Lightning, maybe, that's not the smart idea.
True.
Right.
Yeah.
And you like the rain when you're inside?
I like that too.
I like thunderstorms.
But you can't hear it on the windows.
Rei-senpai does not like thunderstorms.
No.
Yeah.
But you know, we hope you got a bunch of great photos of the water there.
And that you made sure to dry off too afterwards.
Yeah.
No catching a cold, got it?
That's a must.
BAU BAU!
If you catch a cold then you can't go on as many walks, right?
No.
And for the Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Fuwawa!
What's something you wish more people would notice about Mococo?
Mococo, what's something you wish more people would notice about Fuwawa?
This is tricky.
I feel like this is a really hard one.
Good question.
It's tricky because, you know, we're twins.
I mean... You know... I mean, hopefully you've realized, but, you know, Fuwawa is really sweet and loving.
She likes to be silly.
You know, sometimes.
Just like me, you know.
Just sometimes.
And we tease each other equally.
Yeah.
So, you know, when sometimes I see stuff like Ruffians or people calling her evil, it makes me sad.
At least I wouldn't see that so much.
But I think a lot of people out there just don't recognize her personality or get to know her well enough, and so they make assumptions to fill in the gaps.
She's really sweet too, just like me of course.
Moco-chan you're pretty sweet.
We are twins.
And you know... Guys, even though she doesn't hold the controller too much... It doesn't mean that she's bad at games.
I'm not bad at games.
No.
I help you so much, right Moco-chan?
Yeah!
Always!
Never gets stuck.
Yeah.
We're a team!
It doesn't mean that she's not a pro gamer.
That's all.
Almost more pro than you?
No.
I got today's top in-house event!
Android boys!
Today's?
Yeah!
Well, the other day, that day.
BAU BAU!
Thanks Moco-chan!
More people notice about Moco-chan.
Moco-chan is really sweet.
Her tummy gets upset when she's nervous.
Most of the time she's nervous because she wants you to notice something.
That's important, right?
Yeah.
Moco-chan would like you to read our brains more.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a bit of a hard one, huh?
But FUWAMO, we can't share with you with our brains and head parts before I ask for them.
But we'll try and share that with our songs, right?
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Happy.
Pero Sighting.
I like Pero Sighting.
It's just a nice, yummy, delicious pero cake.
Cake Sighting.
And some very wonderful questions.
As well as logs too.
We're always looking for many more too, Ruffians.
So please share them with us.
The hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at our next stream coming up here.
The thumbnail is still...
Being designed.
But!
Let's take a look at the schedule.
Next at 6pm PT today, we're gonna be having an Advent collab!
This time we're playing Old Market Simulator for the first time!
Moco-chan, this is a game you really wanted to play all together.
We're gonna have a market together.
Like an RPG kind of like market?
I want it to be an old market.
And business.
Business together with Advent.
Are we rivals?
No.
Team.
Oh.
Is Biboo gonna raise the chickens?
And then Shiori the cows?
We'll figure it out!
Please join us, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
If we take a look at our schedule here more, you might notice, Ruffians, that there's no Friday FUWAMOCO on the schedule.
But that isn't a mistake.
It's just temporary for now.
But we're going to be doing only one FUWAMOCO Morning a week on Mondays for a little bit here.
Even though today is Wednesday.
Yeah, even though today is a Wednesday.
You know, there are some things that we really want to do and need to get done.
We think you know.
We're pretty busy puppies, and we get kinda tired by the end of a busy day.
So we think that it's best if we try this out for a little bit.
And you know, you see how we feel from there.
Thank you for understanding, Ruffians.
No problem.
I didn't say that.
Let's take care of our feelings!
BAU BAU!
And if we take another look at the schedule, you can see we have some more Metal Gear Solid 3 fun!
Maybe this time we're gonna finish the game.
Maybe the end!
As well as we're playing a brand new game called Cornered Dimension Girl that looks very very cute!
We'll have to check that one out altogether because I don't know much about it except for that it looks cute and Moco-chan wanted to play it.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Chopper Scout.
Midnight Star.
BAU BAU!
Happy Hobie.
Warchelor.
BAU BAU!
Alidora.
Absor.
BAU BAU!
Steve Jones.
Vampire.
BAU BAU!
Beast Gorilla.
Pizza Enjoyer.
BAU BAU!
Bijou.
Nanor.
BAU BAU!
The Virtual Dance.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!